all right hennessey
hi hennessey uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally i'm from
stockton california that's up north
stockton here and tell me about your
family growing up you had both your
parents so i didn't have both my parents
both of my parents
are also
in the game too though oh they are yeah
so your dad is a pimp and your mom is uh
oh wow
do you remember that growing up
um i
honestly i really wasn't home like that
my mom used to
put us like different homes and stuff so
basically my mom used to
she's a hoe so she didn't have time to
take care of it like that so basically i
just grew up knowing that my mom is a
hug who is raising your grandparents um
a bunch of random people
like it's hard for into the game type
stuff
so if i i don't have it's like i'm
pregnant now so it's hard for me
i don't know what to do like because you
never had any parents yeah wow
so you're pregnant right now yeah how
far along are you i'm only a couple
months i just found out but you know who
the father is
um
yeah
it's it's complicated
like he's from my
my city type stuff so i really don't
talk to him like that
so
and you've been doing this kind of work
for how long
um since i was 16 how old are you now i
am 19 years old 19.
did you finish high school
no i didn't
how far did you go um probably like when
i was freshman and i didn't
feel like like a normal kid
there was a lot of stuff going on in
home so right
so like for do you have anyone you
consider family now
um i have a best friend
um
[Music]
i have
my baby daddy's part of the family but
i don't really talk to him like that for
me to
always help with this search to think
with the baby i'm gonna need this for
the you know so the day like
i do certain things as me being a hulk
so in a day he don't really like it
so
no i really don't have family life so
you have no support system for no
raising your child
yeah
that would be hard if you're on the
streets for
a big part of the day or at a job even
yeah
um
and you work on your independent or you
work for the family i'm i'm actually
independent right now
you've had times
i did
i did have when he passed away oh wow so
it's hard to choose
somebody else when
he was with that person so many long
years yeah was he like a boyfriend as
well
no not like that like he was because i
was his only
like person that he had
so
and you uh
you keep the money now yeah are you
saving money yes you're gonna need it
for the baby yeah
what are the hardest parts of this kind
of work for you
um
me being autistic
so you're autistic yes how does that
play into this because i like you
some people say that i look like a baby
or
i have to take pills to control my mood
swings because
a lot of autistic people they fidget
with their hands a lot or they play with
their ears or they cover their ears
so i have to take meds to
keep that
down
so
but interacting with all these
all these
people strangers yeah it's like it's
scary like it's to me but any day i'm
my mom like i said they i was around a
lot of stuff when i turned to searching
age yeah
did you see your mom doing it um a
couple times but i wasn't really focused
for my mom being oh my mom's just trying
to take get money just to take care of
us like
my mom didn't pay my dad to the point
that she could have called him
but we call our folks typestick
like so today we call our dad and we
call our like daddies or type stuff we
are
this is a younger generation
my mom's older
so
so it's kind of harder like mama was
independent too though so
my mom was in this the clubs and
my mom was on internet more than
walking
what we do
oh you so you work the streets more yeah
i'm in the streets more
have you had bad things happen to you
doing that
um a couple of times
yeah
you have to be careful now because yeah
soon you'll have a child and
working the streets is gonna
the dangers become much more really
scary you have to come home every night
how does this kind of work affect you
emotionally emotionally
it's it's some type of downfall
like me
i could say i really be scared a lot
because i don't have
of him so
[Music]
emotionally it's scary because there's a
lot of
it's a lot of stuff that goes on
on the streets
so
it's scary
to me
yeah
did you have did you have dreams of
doing something else with your life
yeah i used to dream being a model and a
chef and
taking care of my family and stuff
probably singing when i was you know
like dreaming like as a little girl type
stuff
how did you introduce to this
i was
so
my
my person so i had a boyfriend a long
time
a minute ago
um
and i was
i i didn't really know that what he was
doing
in
when i wasn't around him
type stuff
and
one day i was struggling
and i asked him
i asked him i need to go get money type
stuff because
i can't
my mom just kept me up
my mom was on drugs so i really didn't
know what to do as 16
growing up in stockton california
and it's a lot of it's crazy out there
so it's a it's not it's not like l.a but
it's
more than
it's if you go to oakland
it's whole it's more hoes
than stockton type stuff
so
one day i was like i just want to go to
oakland see how
honestly i brought myself into this
because
i was like well i'm ready finding out
that my mom is a hoe so i want to see
how it's really going to turn me out
as me being a woman and a young so
basically i wanted to do this
i wanted to do it wasn't
it wasn't a force or it was my choice
and i always got to think of that like
because of the day i brought myself into
this because i asked my boyfriend oh i
just need to go get minnie
he was like all right you know and
honestly he was okay with it like
because in the day he was doing it
when i wasn't
really focused what he was doing
do you remember your parents
relationship when you were young um
my dad i used to just know that i used
to go to work with him and
work because my dad used to do cars
so
but he was also a pit so basically
i used to be around different different
women's that he had
but it was it was like kind of weird
with me like it was i wasn't really
around my mom a lot i wasn't around my
dad a lot
so if i was with my dad
i most likely would work with him
when
but he used to break like you know break
on his hose at work
so it was okay like i didn't know what
was going on i thought he would just go
i thought they were just giving him
paychecks or something
so
this is is this a lonely
life for you
it's lonely yeah cuz i don't have nobody
like that i can't
run home and go talk to mom or
talk to none of my siblings or something
do you have friends um not close friends
but
friends
like
associates or
acquaintances i don't really call i
can't really have friends like that like
i can't trust people like that because
of this type of game
what was the hardest part of this
life for you
um when i saw
when i saw one of the
when i saw somebody die in front of me
that's the first thing
like it scared me like
so today i'm i'm i'm young so i'm 19
like i said so it's like
it's it's scary for me like watching
somebody die how did they die
robbery
it's a dangerous life you guys are
living yeah
what mistakes have you made that you've
learned from
choosing up
what a different dude they used to
beat me up all the time
and not take care of me
how
a girl is bringing a lot of money in for
you
and
you're going to be here
after
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that do women that
do this kind of work
um i don't i don't i don't know how to
like really say about that because
a lot of these girls
i don't never had wifeys
and so
i can't say
and talk to a lot of girls because
they like i say you just know your own
i'm by myself
tell me about the guys that
are your clients
um i have a lot
i mean so it's a lot like i have
most likely like over
a thousand regulars
really
a thousand yes
because i'm young
i'm only 19 so and i'm beautiful so
and
i'm puerto rican
so basically it's a lot of mexicans that
i date it's a triple threat there yeah
so they'd be like oh she's beautiful
type stuff i want a lot of her
so you stay busy
yeah
it'll be hard for you to turn down this
money i'm really happy and go get a job
yeah
do you have any regrets about doing this
kind of work
sometimes yeah
sometimes maybe a lot of times
like it's
sometimes it's really hard just to
wake up
in the evening
just to go to work
i
i wake up and i'll be like what is how's
this day gonna mean like how does this
night go be
uh
sometimes i'd be like oh
what if a girl tries to fight me again
today
because how i live
or how much money i make they don't have
a problem with it
like i don't flex
how much i make because then they
this type of game
it's not for flexing
at all
it's just i i flex my body type stuff
how do you think doing this kind of work
has changed you
i just see a really a quiet person
and i talked more
than
i already didn't know i could talk this
much like i really used to i was
introductory yeah
yeah i used to not dance i used to
not feel
me
are drugs a part of your life no no
drugs no that's great
most of your uh clients are married you
think
yeah i think
i don't ask them that
what have you learned about men
from all this they're crazy
um
and
they're weird they're they're i don't
know it should be like dang like
if i would have been in a relationship
what would my man do but he would
go dead oh or go pay my money just to
you know
go day to day and fall type stuff
is it does this doing this kind of work
make it hard for you to trust a man
yeah
a lot
really it'd be
hard because
it'd be like dang they gonna really go
date somebody like i like i like life
skipping so it's like
a lot of i did a lot of light skin
from doing this
and they paid me times there so they
made me like they
what if i did the light skin not being
what i am
and they go
date a three or
what hours do you typically work um
sometimes
sometimes i usually work at this time
but i had stuff to do today
early in the morning so i didn't work
like in the daytime but i usually do two
shifts
um i do the daytime
so
that's to like
eleven to like three o'clock
then i play night time that's six
to
three o'clock in the morning
i've heard like sometimes like
four or five in the morning is the
busiest time because guys are
leaving early for work
and making a stop on the way there
yeah
what advice would you give to a young
woman who's thinking of doing this kind
of stuff
just pick the right person to work with
because there'll be a lot that don't
take care of you
and treat you that as your beautiful
woman that you is
so
and sometimes they don't sit down and
talk to you
you could go through a lot you could go
through
emotional disorders
and
your your folks don't know
what you're going through
do you get risky
requests from your clients
yes
yes i do and a to the point that i've
been saying no yeah
i sometimes it'd be a lot that say oh
certain nasty stuff like let me you know
like i'll be like no i can't do that i
can't risk it
what's the weirdest thing you've been
asked to do
so i assumed the web the internet
and
it was one that asked me
can i
can i [ __ ] him in his dog
his dog not
his partner
a dog
like a dog
so you're wearing a strap on
or or
no his dog is going to hug me i've been
of course with you
wow
and it's type of stuff that i said even
if it was
he said for 2k
i'm honestly i'm not going to do nothing
for 2k who was with an
makes you proud to be a man
wow
scary yeah
it's crazy what what what regrets do you
have
i got regrets because i
[Music]
i missed a lot of
time with my dad
um my dad recently passed away
i'm sorry
so
if
it's just it's
things that i pushed off with him
before i knew he had he had cancer so
when it was recent
things that he needed me to go talk to
him or lay up with him and you know talk
to him instead and see how i was doing
when i told him no i care
because i was doing this
and what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned
in your 19 years um
family
even if you can't
be with them all the time
then
i agree a lot
because
i miss my dad
you know my dad was one of my
when a person i used to run to my mom
used to do
messed up stuff
so you're closer to your dad yeah
you used to call him like dad pick me up
your intuition must be heightened from
doing this kind of work
yeah and trying to figure out who's safe
to get in the car with and who's not yes
and i'd be like i'm not going to date
certain people or i'm not going to talk
to
whoever because they
i don't i i'm really i'm really a nice
girl like i'm a nice person i'm fun
i'm
a little crazy
you got to be crazy to do this kind of
work oh yeah
do you have clients that get attached to
you
yes
i do i have two that wants me to get
married today
you have marriage for puzzles yes
they always be like let me just go get
you a ring
like i want to marry you
like no
you can't take care of me
would falling in love be difficult for
you given this lifestyle yeah
i think i would think uh
yeah a boyfriend who's not
in the game would you have a hard time
with what you're doing yeah i hadn't i
first left when i was like 14 years old
though and
i couldn't deal with him like that
because
i was
not be able to do certain things i
couldn't go outside and hang out
i probably had to watch younger siblings
or something i take care of cook or do
assist the big sister things
our mom thinks that i'm a young
i got two younger
siblings so you kind of played mom yeah
to them
but
mom's a whole
do you think if your parents weren't
had square jobs weren't in the game your
life would not have taken probably
probably
but
if
maybe if
if they were
square jobs yeah
if there was a perfectly happy family
yeah it probably would have changed
me doing this
right
all right hennessey thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you i wish
you the best of luck out there
be careful good luck with your baby too
thank you
you